30 ans ça se fait les Templiers d'lancou
ont passé le cap de la trentaine au
complexe sportif Europe avec une grande
manifestation des petits match des
démonstrations de cheer leaders et une
exposition photo retraçant l'histoire du
club é é organisé ce samedi en présence
du staff des joueurs et des ancien
séquence émotion pour les Templiers
qu'est-ce que ça m'inpire oui
effectivement que j'ai pris 30 ans
puisque bah j'étais là au premier
entraînement des corpmant qui sont
devenus par la suite les les Templiers
donc voilà ça nous rajunit pas mais
c'est une très belle fête aujourd'hui
voilà on retrouve les anciens tout le
monde a pris 30 ans il y a pas que moi
un plaisir de faire partie de cette
famille et une envie de
relève envie de prendre le relais et de
prendre de succéder à nos coachs plein
de souvenirs plein plein
d'amitié plein de VoyaG et voilà des des
gens que que j'ai pasevu depuis 20 25
voir 30 ans tout début et qui vont
arriver les uns après les autres au fil
de la journée en 30 ans le club a évolué
la structure qui a connu six présidents
des dizaines de coachs et passé de 45
adhérents à 270 footballeurs américains
aujourd'hui les Templiers se sont
également professionnalisé pour faire
partie des meilleures équipes de
l'Hexagone avant c'était un jeu on va
dire on se taper dessus sans trop sans
trop savoir pourquoi aujourd'hui c'est
beaucoup plus technique physique les
gars ils font de la musculation deux
trois fois par semaine voilà on est
vraiment dans les standards du football
américain tel qu'on peut le l'approcher
aux États-Unis on se rapproche de de
plus en plus à l'époque non à l'époque
c'était on se rentrait dedans avec un
ballon au milieu et puis voilà quoi
prochain objectif pour les 30 prochaines
années des Templiers faire remonter
l'équipe une en première division et
l'installer dans le top 3 des équipes
françaises en développant en parallèle
la formation des jeunes